the conservative party and its mps have
a clear choice and and it will tell us
whether they have no confidence in boris
johnson or whether they have no backbone
because they can't surely believe that
boris johnson is the best that the
conservative party has to offer and
ultimately if conservative mps now
choose to cling to boris johnson they
will be complicit in his behavior
they'll be solid by his behavior and
they will send a message to the country
that boris johnson is the best that they
have to offer and all the while this is
going on the big challenges facing the
country the cost of living crisis the
huge nhs backlog the challenges for our
public services and our economy go on
unanswered because the only focus of
conservative mps now is boris johnson's
future not the future of the country
yeah but there'll be a vote and he'll
win
well we'll see about that okay i mean if
conservative mps are daft enough to go
into the general election led by boris
johnson the contrast between kirsten and
boris johnson is one that i would relish
but i think that's a terrible position
to put the country in they can't
possibly believe that boris johnson is
the answer to the country's problems
because he is part of the problem
himself and don't take my word for it i
mean there's been a note circulating by
conservative mps um you know which has
been circulated on social media and it
says and i quote the entire purpose of
the government now appears to be the
sustenance of boris johnson as prime
minister it says and i quote partygate
and the prime minister's denials of it
in the house of commons represent a
major breach of trust with the british
population and they're right so the only
question now is whether conservative mps
have the courage to act to give the
country better leadership and if they
won't labor certainly will at the next
general election
if he wins will you get off his back
i don't see how boris johnson can win in
this situation but let me look at the
scenes we saw over the weekend the whole
country was united around the jubilee
with some fantastic events the only
point of division across the whole
weekend was the prime minister himself
being booed and don't tell me that those
crowds outside saint paul's cathedral
were some kind of you know partisan
labor crowd i think they were speaking
for the country people have had enough
they're fed up with being lied to
they're fed up with being let down and i
think they are now expecting their
conservative mps to act and you know
voters will draw their own conclusions
if if conservative mps don't act i think
the voters will at the ballot box we've
already started to see that happening in
the local elections
it wasn't the only point of division as
you well know there was booing for megan
and harry as well but my point is if he
does win the vote of confidence will you
then get off his back
we we can never entertain having
confidence in boris johnson and we will
keep on holding into account for the
lies for the rule breaking and for the
failure to deliver on the issues that
matter to people whether it's the 15
tory tax rises including the the rise in
national insurance during a cost of
living crisis whether it's the record
nhs backlog which was at record levels
before the pandemic the way in which
they let children down who suffered
terribly during the pandemic and have
failed to deliver the children's
recovery plan that we need you know on
every single front on the economy on our
public services on on basic delivery of
government projects and programs
this this government is incompetent it's
out of touch and that culture that
failure
is set from the top boris johnson can't
be part of the answer to the country's
challenges because he's a big part of
the problem
but if you can't uncease him as prime
minister surely you have to look at your
own leadership and whether they are
sufficient enough to as get rid of the
prime minister that you think is not fit
for purpose
well if conservative mps won't remove
the prime minister this week the labour
party will make sure that we remove the
prime minister at the next general
election and we will do that not just
relying on boris johnson's failure and
the failure of the conservative
government but by setting out a clear
labor alternative which inspires the
country and gives people the confidence
that we can deliver and on the cost of
living crisis we've given some
indication already about the different
kinds of choices that labour would make
we wouldn't be hiking up taxes on
working people our focus would be on
cutting those taxes to put money back in
their pockets we'd ask the wealthier to
contribute more through things like
taxes on shares and dividends and
property we think that would be fairer
than hurting people in their pockets
that's why we're calling for an
emergency budget this week
to make sure that we've got the action
now on the cost of living crisis but i
doubt any conservative mp is even
thinking about
an emergency budget to tackle the cost
of living crisis let alone planning for
one because the only thing they're
talking about the only show in town is
the clown show of boris johnson's
leadership and i just hope that
conservative mps who've apparently been
wrestling with their consciences we saw
one minister in the newspaper this
weekend saying well i don't have any
confidence in boris johnson but
apparently they don't have the courage
to act well this is the opportunity now
if they're calling a leadership uh vote
of no confidence that's the right thing
to do i now urge conservative mps to do
the right thing by your country give the
country better leadership give the
country leadership it deserves and you
know are you seriously saying i mean
satya javid referred to the conservative
party as the most successful
political party in the history of
western democracy are they really saying
now that that party which has enjoyed so
much success over centuries now offers
boris johnson's the very best they've
got to offer and as i say if they're
daft enough to keep him on then the
contrast between kierstarma and boris
johnson is one we will relish at the
next election but i think that would be
a gross betrayal of this country
everything it stands for don't just take
my word for it look at the devastating
words that are being deployed publicly
by conservative mps including now by
um jesse norman a johnson supporter in
the leadership contest who who's
catalogued in excruciating brutal detail
the fact that boris johnson is a threat
to the union of the united kingdom not
focused on the right priorities with
daft ideas like privatizing channel 4
breaking promises breaking treaties you
know it's not just the fact that but
that he's lied uh to the country it's
not just the fact he's broken the rules
on lockdown it's the fact that on so
many of the big issues facing the
country boris johnson is failing as our
prime minister and failing to give the
people the leadership they deserve
okay that was quite an answer wasn't it
good job i'm not in the studio with you
the point remains though it could well
be another two years before you find
yourselves in a position to be able to
unseat boyce johnson and you have to
accept that as a fact
it it it could be kay but it you know it
will be the voters who judge
conservative mps very harshly for that
and rightly so i don't think that the
conservative mps can possibly say hand
on heart that boris johnson is the best
they've got to offer or is providing the
leadership the country deserves and so
they have a basic democratic duty now to
do the right thing and remove him
and what if they don't
there's nothing you can do about it then
then voters will judge them and we will
take him on at the next election and
make sure that kierstarma is giving the
country the leadership it deserves as
our next prime minister stand by stand
by stand by just hearing confirmation
that there will be a vote of confidence
in the prime minister there will be a
vote of confidence in the prime minister
today between six and eight pm between
six and eight pm now then it's up to you
guys to try and sort that one out isn't
it uh we're streeting
no it's i mean if i wish i had a vote i
mean i'd be straight in there but the
the conservative mps have to sort this
one out you know this is this is up to
them now they've called the vote of no
confidence that's the right thing to do
finally about time they now need to do
the right thing and put the country
first the voters are watching and they
will be judging no confidence or no
backbone that's the choice now facing
conservative mps as they go to vote this
evening